hello everyone and thank you for coming
to this talk and thank you to the
organizers for arranging this conference
in a in difficult situations so i'm
going to talk about some work i've done
with luka zanetti on the farthest mixing
markov chain problem
okay so what what is this
question
uh we have we're given a graph g
and our goal is to sample uniformly from
its vertex set v
and we we are allowed to do this via a
markov chain
but the markov chain is only allowed to
make transitions across edges in
the edge set of the graph in a
we're trying to sample uniformly from v
so we choose a markov chain with uniform
invariant distribution and naturally we
want the mixing time to be as fast as
possible
so formally this is a minimization
program we want to minimize the mixing
time which has a precise definition in
terms of the first time the total
variation distance
between the law of the chain and uniform
is smaller than a quarter
want to minimize this overall
transition matrices which are stochastic
have uniform invariant distribution and
have this uh local property that exists
on on
on the graph
[Music]
here u is the uniform distribution
and the termination distance it
sort of quantifies how easily it is how
easy it is to distinguish two measures
okay so we're going to do a couple of
simplifications first is to only
consider reversible markup chains
and in particular we're considering the
uniform environment distribution but
we're requiring a uniform event
distribution so this
imposes that our
transition matrix are
chosen transition matrices are symmetric
okay reversible reversible marker chains
are characterized by random walks on
weighted graphs
that is given any reversible markov
chain you could always define a graph
and a weighting on all that graphs such
that the reversal markov chain is given
by the random walk on this weighted
graph and the converse also holds
so in essence we're looking for an
optimal weighting of a graph
we're also only interested in
bounds of this fastest mixing markov
chain problem up to constant factors
and so
we're happy to impose laziness um
and this has this is helpful because
then all our
spectrum is
uh is non-negative
okay the the mixing time there is a
rather delicate object it depends on the
norm which we've chosen as total
variation it also depends on the
starting location and
the precision parameter epsilon
instead of looking at the mixing time
we're going to look at the relaxation
time and use this as a as a proxy for
the for for the mixing time
it's well known that
the relaxation time and the mixing time
differ by
at most a logarithmic factor
um
the this same proxy has been used in the
majority of previous work on the fastest
mixing markup chain problem
in in in in particular this uh false
mixing markov chain problem was
introduced by boyd darkness and zhao
uh in a series of paper also with
prolonged and sun and some other papers
and uh they they've looked at not
necessarily mixing but the but the
optimal spectral gap or optimal uh
relaxation time
so these dates you might wonder why
they're not in order the dates are the
publication dates not necessarily
corresponding to the
order in which they were written
okay but so basically boyd darkest and
xiao introduced it in their first paper
the classic mixing market chain on an
honor graph
and they studied
things like uh showing that the faster
mixing market chain problem is an stp
and so you can solve it
reasonably quickly with standard
sdp solvers and they also looked a bit
at the dual but then rock looked at the
dual end did a lot more work with the
jewel and
did some stuff with variational
characterizations which we'll come to
later
and then uh phil and khan did some work
on it a bit more recently and a bit more
recently
and chan did as
well
okay our results
we have two main results uh and
therefore discrete time chains
uh we also have some additional results
an additional result for continuous time
chains as well as one for a time in
objectives chains but but i won't
mention the latter two here i'll just
focus on the main two
okay so the first one
is basically that vertex conductance
characterizes fast mixing so let's let
um
let's set c denote the vertex
conductance of a autograph
and then
the fastest reversible mixing time
uh satisfies
this cheega type
inequality so um i've got the mixing
time on on the right but this is a
consequence of the
of the relaxation time
so this is like chiga but we have this
extra log n factor
okay the second theorem is an existence
of a fast or what we call almost mixing
chain
so given a fixed epsilon
uh positive then there always exists a
reversible transition matrix p
satisfying
uh relaxation time being at most
diameter squared and having invariant
distribution
that is
uh epsilon close to two uniform so every
verb is so even stronger than apps on
closer to termination every vertex
is
at most a factor one minus epsilon
smaller than
u than the corresponding uniform
okay so
now
i'll i'll just do a couple of examples
and then we'll talk briefly about how to
prove these two statements
so i'll just let fee and c get out the
edge of vertex conductances respectively
and just a reminder that chiga's
inequality
says that the relaxation time for the
simple random walk is characterized by
the
uh by the
edge conductance in in this particular
form
okay so first example is to have two
cliques of size n
and then connect these or maybe another
two um and then connect these
by a perfect matching
now the simple random walk on this graph
has mixing time that's order n
uh indeed for order n steps it will stay
in whichever clique it starts because
each time there are n minus one that uh
edges that lead to other
vertices in the clique and one that
leads to the other click so it's going
to take order n to swap clicks
uh and yeah this is this uh last
statement that i just said it's kind of
shown by the fact that the
edge conductance is order one over n
so in particular if you take one click
there are n squared edges inside and
order n coming out so this gives you
uh
this gives you conductance one over n
the vertex conductance on the other hand
is order one
uh in particular if we take um if we
take one click then there are
n vertices in that click and they're
also n vertices adjacent to that tweak
so when where we aren't using the fact
that there are a large number of
internal edges we only have a number of
vertices
so so this you can actually show them
that the vertex conductor is order one
and so our theorem says that
there does exist a fast mixing markov
chain
um
that
ideally you'd have spectral gap or order
one or right station time order order
one but there could be this logarithmic
factor if you recall from our
for our theorem but actually we can
construct quite easily a chain that
mixes in time order one and how do we do
this
we place a we place weight one
a unit weight on all of the edges inside
the cliques
and then place
a weight n minus one on all of the edges
that connect the two clicks
okay so now if we're at a vertex
there
there's weight n minus one going to
other elements of the same click and
weight n minus one going to the other
click
so if you take a step inside the clique
you mix inside the clique or you swap to
the other click
so basically you just need to do each of
these you need to make sure you've got a
good enough property of swapping and a
good enough probability of being
randomized but each of these has
probability approximately a half of
happening so it takes time order one for
this to happen and thus the relaxation
time is uh is order one
okay the second example is similar where
we now have two cliques
but we consider one having a sort of
source where k edges come out of it to
connect to the other side so i've shown
here k being three
so the simple random walk on this graph
you can check has mixing time n squared
over k
in particular if you start in the right
hand click it's going to take you time n
squared over k to
exit it'll take your time order n to hit
the source node and then when you go
here there are k out of
there k going out and n coming back in
so you have a
order n squared over k
okay and this is again you know
emphasized by the fact that the edge
conductance is k over n squared
but the vertex conductance um is just
one over n
if you take as you're set to the left
hand click then you'll see that there
are n vertices and one on on the
boundary
so we have order one over n and in
particular this is independent of of k
because it didn't matter that there were
k edges coming out because they all went
to the same
node so all that matters is how many
vertices there are so this is order one
over n
and so we can create uh we can create a
a chain with next thing with rational
time that's
either that somewhere between n and n
squared
log n
and in particular you can do this in
uh
you can get one with a relaxation time
that's order n
how would you do
this you can use a specification
technique so
you take each of the cliques and just
specify them to get a
three regular expander graph
i'd also remove all of the connecting
edges
between the source and
the
between the two clicks except for one
and then
you get
two clicks which each have uh which each
are three regular expanders
and and then it's not particularly
difficult to check that this has mix er
this has recommendation time order n
indeed internally the raxation time for
each one is one but it takes time order
and to swap between the two clicks
so we can actually use this
specification technique to go back to
the first a
example and there's another way of
constructing a
an order one right station time chain
so take the two clicks and just specify
them to get three regular a expanders
add the same three like a three regular
expander on either side
and then
the graph now is just two copies of the
same graph just connected up where your
corresponding pairs are
are connected so it's actually quite
easy to
to check in this case that if one of the
graphs in this copy is
uh is as an expander then
then so is the other one
so in particular
the whole graph is an expander and we
get a relaxation time order one via
specification
okay those are my two examples
[Music]
i now want to talk a little bit about
the proofs
so first we're going to talk about the
characterization of fast mixing which is
a chia type inequality for the optimal
realization time
so i mentioned very briefly earlier that
rock used duality to establish a
variational characterization
and precisely there's this variational
characterization now the precise details
are are a little bit technical
but
the point to observe is that if you fix
a function f
and then optimize over g so then the
minimization the value is a function of
f
then this yields a linear program for a
fractional matching on a weighted graph
where the weight is given by this
function of
of f
okay so now instead of before we were
thinking about like edge conductance and
vertex conductance now we've got
something in terms of a fractional
matching
and so we introduce matching conductions
so precisely and matching as a set of
edges with no common endpoint
and let's denote by m of s the value of
the maximum weight matching
on
the
on the cut between s and s complement
uh and this weight is here in the
previous um
is just with weight one on each edge
okay and now i'll let very similar to
the definition of edge and vertex
connections let's let epsilon of of s
be this weight divided by
uh the smaller of the size of the set
and the size of its complement
and then epsilon of g is just the
minimum over all sets sets that aren't
the empty set or the full set
so they don't have zero in the
denominator
okay so
we call this the matching conductance
and you can actually check that this is
of the same order as a vertex
conductance uh with a uniform constant
over the graph um so this is uniformly
in the graph
but
something that would be very important
for our analysis
is that actually for some sets the
matching conductions can be way smaller
than the vertex conductions
and so our analysis really doesn't work
with vertex conductions but it works
with matching conductance so this you
know introducing this new matching
conductors conductance is really
absolutely key for the
fuller proof
and so our our main theorem is just you
know this is just a restatement of of
the other one really is to prove this
chiga type inequality but for matching
conductance
now as as you see these have got to up
to constants in there so you could
replace matching conductance with
vertex conductance but the point is i'm
trying to emphasize that the proof
really uses matching conductions and
then you say at the end oh look magic
conductance is the same as this
more well-known vertex conductance
so i just wanted to say a very few words
other on the proof
the lower bound you just do this via a
via test function which is you know a
fairly common way
but the upper bound is a bit more
complicated there are two main steps and
if you're familiar with how proofs of
um these sorts of things go in
particular chiga-like constants the
steps perhaps won't be super surprising
to you but yeah they're still
just because the idea is that
it's still difficult to to do
so first of all we reduce it to a
one-dimensional problem using johnson
linder strauss lemma
and then we study matching conductance
of these sweeps that's
defined as shown
so the first step is where this extra
factor of log n on the right arises
and i mentioned in at the end a little
bit about removing this factor
well we can't ruin this factor but
uh
comment about
how it would be nice to
okay so that's the
that is the
matching conductance and the
characterization
now i just want to talk very briefly
about even more briefly about the
almost mixing construction and for this
we use a weighted spanning tree
so the idea is to choose
some
arbitrary rooted breakfast breadth first
search tree
and then suitably wait it
we then adjust the holding probabilities
to make the invariant distribution close
to uniform
okay the precise construction
uh we we first denote by t of x or t
subset of x
the sub the subtree rooted at x so
t is a tree with a hierarchical
structure a
root and then offspring and so on
so let's denote tx
the subtree if you were to just look at
x and everything below
now we let the weight of the edge from x
to its parent
be
proportional to
the size of
this tree tx so the number of vertices
beneath it
uh including itself
but then we but then we have to down
weight this
and we down weight this by a factor that
is
uh proportional to epsilon over the
diameter of the tree
but the key for choosing a breadth first
a breadth first search tree and actually
the only reason for choosing this
is that the diameter of this bfs tree is
the same order as the diameter of the
graph
it's obviously at least the diameter of
the graph but it's actually almost twice
the twice a diameter because you could
just go via the root
so all you need is a tree that has
diameter the same order as the diameter
of the graph
we then augment this tree with uh this
weighted tree with unit weight self
loops
okay and so this waiting helps the
random walk to exit traps and
bottlenecks and uh and the like
why
for example
suppose that a certain part of the graph
contains a large number of vertices
but it's poorly connected connected to
the rest of the graph for example it
might have just a single edge e
connecting it to the rest of the graph
and assume that the rest of the graph
contains contains the root
this means that the and the weight of
the edge e
is
the number of vertices in s which we've
assumed is is is large
and so the weights of the edges neary
are are also lodged by the construction
uh and so this kind of encourages the
walk to exit s via the edge e and and to
do so fairly quickly
okay and then just a closing slide on
on open on open questions and problems
the first one is that we would like to
remove the log n factor in the chiga
type inequality
but you can't remove everything you need
a log dmax factor
uh unless the small set expansion
hypothesis is uh is false
um so we're explaining a bit more in the
paper exactly why why why this is but
you do need some factor it's not it's
not true in general without any factor
so we'd also like to generalize the
chiga type inequality to non-uniform
invariant distributions
now
we thought this might be fairly uh this
might be fairly easy and it's and it is
easy to get really trivial bounds that
involve you know factors of pi min over
pi max and stuff like that but
we have we weren't able to prove it
uh
the same sort of result for general for
general invariant
distributions and so this is certainly
an important open question
the almost mixing construction actually
already immediately extends basically
just instead of looking at the
cardinality of a set you look at the
invariant measure of of a third
okay could we obtain more explicit
constructions of fast mixing chains
uh if you remember in the examples that
i gave we
reconstructed them explicitly and
actually we often used in both cases we
could use specification techniques
so perhaps we can uh perhaps you can do
some sort of spectral specification or
something like this to show
to construct more explicitly a fast
mixing chain
uh this was actually our first uh our
first
method of
you know our first method but we weren't
able to do this as well as we'd like and
then we found this method with matching
conductance
and lastly are there any uh algorithmic
applications
all the all the previous work on
faster's mixing markov chain
had been to do with lower bounds or it
it's either been characterizing the
problem as
convex and stuff like this
uh all proving lower bounds because the
dual result normally improves uh lower
bounds
so we were the odds of the first you
know
some non-trivial results on our upper
bounds and could there be some
algorithmic uh application or view even
some more abstract applications where
you say that there does exist some fast
mixing markov chain
um
yeah so if everyone has some of these
please please please do contact us let
us know we'd love to hear about it
okay that's it uh thank you everyone for
listening